based off of our connection and just you
being a friend I need to show you
my two tech companies and get your
perspective on it
because now I have friends that can give
a perspective like when I would work on
albums I had other friends that worked
on albums and they would give me their
perspectives on it you wanna do this we
are doing it this is part of it this is
part of it absolutely all right
beautiful oh what I wanted to finish the
thing is okay you're going to ask me
different questions but I'm about
growing and building and bringing the
idea to life so when I see you I say oh
this guy understands how to hire
Engineers where I'm coming from coming
from Hollywood coming from press coming
from media all of the guys you know that
so many of the guys that have been like
voices and faces and Talking Heads
whatever have not understood how to
engineer products and that's the reason
why I was able to jump past everyone in
the entertainment field and become
um you know whatever the net worth is 11
billion I'm gonna stop putting the whole
black thing on my worth like let's just
see where I am on the scale of life
because that's a cop-out for me to say
richest black guy of all time because
that's feeding into the same you know
trauma economy that black lives matter
feeds into that's why I love and respect
Engineers that's the only thing that we
really need to teach in school is
engineering we don't need to teach
history we don't need to teach anything
that is subjective it needs to only be
engineering taught in school and
everything else needs to be recessed
nothing that at all any Force subjective
information is just to weaken and
indoctrinate
our species and that's what schools do
now as an engineer I love hearing you
say that but to push back history is not
the interpretation of History might be
subjective but history has some facts
and they're useful to give a grounding
to the way you do engineering I don't
100 believe in anything any concept of
the future or any concept of History
because history was just written by The
Victors yeah so if I see stuff happen on
the day that later that day is reported
wrong so how wrong is something reported
a thousand years ago and why would we
argue about something that's not in the
now because that's the only thing that
everyone can agree upon is that it is
now right now yeah you try not to make
the mistakes of the past that's the
usefulness of History The Limited
usefulness the biggest mistake from the
past that we keep making is looking at
the past too much giving too much value
to the past too much value to the past
we are now we are now we are here we are
one species We Are One race
we're here
and
it's time and the leadership is changing
because you have Elon as a leader yea as
a leader and we are the top leaders
we're more influential than the
presidents
so you're a human being
with engineering challenges before you
well the stem player with parlor
what's the hardest thing in front of you
on the engineering front that's the
first sentence that any of our species
needs to hear when they're born
You Are a Human Being when engineering
challenges and I consider consider
challenges to be opportunities in front
of you yeah literally like let me see a
piece for you I need to write that down
that's the beginning of our new species
Constitution
I'm gonna do the paper like this why put
in widescreen this this for Ridley
uh uh you
are
no let me like you
are
a
being
with
in
J Nearing
[Music]
opportunities
or challenges opportunities
I'm sorry I don't spell as good as John
Legend
opportunities
and
be for you
I like the before because it can mean as
you can mean forward or before you this
right here I've always said I'm the top
five writer in human existence but at
this like this right here is pushing me
to like number four number three
it's a good one because who would you
say is the top and it's top right in
human resistant we know who it is that's
subjective who's that it's factual
though it's like okay who's the top
person in Tech History
it's not subjective
well there's a non-subjective answer
to both of those both of those people
have influence 30 percent
of our existence so the influences is
the main metric of greatness okay one
person yeah 30 of our language was the
English language was written by them the
other person 30 of the products we use
was led by them
Steve Jobs yeah
he puts Steve above like elons of the
world because Steve was a designer not
he's a designer engineer but he's a
design he's a Visionary in the design
space well I would lean to him because
I'm not an engineer right so I'm more
like then you're an engineer if if Steve
is an engineer you're an engineer
essentially he's a cultural engineer
like the people who run the emotions of
the world and Run the World off of
people's emotions right now are uh
social engineers and social engineering
is so important like like
um City design there's a fancier word
for that
um but I was uh I was in Ochsner last
night to see Anthony jeselnick and I
gotta find out what his opening joke was
because I'm doing interviews and I'm
thinking I'm funny
and I like that he said he just kept on
saying 20-year anniversary I've been
doing this for 20 years and his opening
joke
was so high level I realized that I
wasn't funny I realized that this dude
is a professional at what he does and so
many things are subjective I always talk
about this it's like you know people are
arguing like it's Emily Ratajkowski the
hottest you know person and I'm like
that's such a subjective thing but like
if you go and shoot three pointers with
Steph Curry it's not subjective right or
if you go and compare bank accounts for
Elon it's not subjective and another
thing that's not subjective
porn
what about it Dick's eyes it's not
subjective you could measure
but porn is more about uh more than just
dick size and greatness is more than the
size of the bank account right so
there's a simple greatness is subjective
though right so you do do you care about
the stuff
that's objective or subjective more
because greatness to me is what matters
the bank account comes and goes
the impact on our society like you said
social engineering the impact on the
collective intelligence of our species
that what permeates throughout the rest
of time I like what you said the impact
I'm taking notes
how did you would you say the impact
collective intelligence of our species
the impact on the
Collective
and
damn
is writing down the words that came out
of my dumb mouth I have made it in life
there's a lot of people that have kind
of like sit through sat through I wanted
to wear a different color hoodie because
I was just tired of seeing this hoodie
and all the interviews and
there's a lot of kids
that are with me they see what I'm
saying yeah and they had to sit through
all of the muck of all the previous
interviews to get to this
every interview
has been
just
an emotional
it's just like been an argument up to
this point this is the first
of
this is the next Frontier of where our
our species is gonna head it starts here
it starts at you Lex
so this is the first time I heard you
say the word engineering at least so
many times which I love hearing so this
is where you're at
you're like that newborn you're a being
with engineering opportunities yeah and
we're all a newborn because then
Christianity say born again we're all
newborns and everyone can uh everyone
shout out like the word Ken uh shell the
only thing about shell is like it kind
of dictates and can kind of kind of lets
people off the hook so I haven't found
the perfect post Shakespeare and post
Steve Jobs and post Elon and post yay
and post Drake way to communicate this
um
but we update and we do and what the
current media structure no it's not
actually nothing that's holding us
there's nothing actually holding us back
because I'm still alive
I'm still alive like they could have
killed me at you know George Bush don't
care about black people they could have
killed me at Beyonce had the best video
but we're here now so we just keep on
leaning and leaning and leaning and
there's these things where I just think
about you know there'll be times when
I'm at War
and
every now and then when the when the
bombs stop going off and all the
headlines and the smearing and all that
stuff going off I think about my family
and I'll think about Kim
and I'll think about how you know King
Koopa has her in the castle right now
and just on uh Mario Brothers you know
how it is just go for the princess and
you get to this level and it's like
I sung the song wrong right and then
they take the princess again
which one are you Mario yeah